i love all your colors you're so ready
for my show thank you very much kelly
clarkson i'm so excited to be at the
show
i love you so wait we just had david
hasselhoff on in your journey stop the
presses stop are you a big fan yes i'm a
large fan i'm a six foot three point
five in fan of david hasselhoff
yeah so y'all i didn't know all the
history on it but the whole freedom song
like i didn't know all of that okay so
you guys know yes david hasselhoff he's
in that show where he's writer yeah he
plays a man with dementia who thinks the
automobile is talking to him
and then at the other show where his nip
his nipples are out all the time and so
this is the best yeah it's so great so
we have both of those shows but in
germany as well as this he's also a pop
star yeah he's like singing about
freedom he's on the rudi karel show
doing nice little pelvi dances it's like
what what what yeah perfect it's like
what what oh my god i love you you
should have your own show i would watch
it every day oh please i'll be your lead
and tonight kelly clarkson where's your
karaoke david hasselhoff
[Music]
you